[Musique]
les plaisirs de télé man l'un des
compositeurs allemands du style baroque
une époque au coeur d'une semaine dédiée
au conservatoire de musique de montigny
le bretonneux
c'est une des périodes qu'on enseigne
aux élèves période baroque c'est la
période de l'expression
des passions des mouvements de l'âme
et c'est notamment ce qu'on demande
souvent aux élèves c'est d'interpréter
des choses et cette période là est tout
à fait propice à l'expression artistique
une découverte avec deux moments phares
des master class dirigée par françois
lazarevitch ce feu système u et east et
le directeur des musiciens de
saint-julien
[Musique]
c'est une belle chose d'enseignés c'est
quelque chose qui me qui personnellement
me passionne parce que c'est une façon
de continuer toujours à se remettre en
question et à servon et on est tous en
chemin réalité alors on a certes un peu
d'avancé puis d'autres sont un peu plus
débutant dans le chemin enfin voila
c'est nous c'est une chaîne on dépasse
le côté un peu scolaire qu'on peut avoir
parfois quand on est avec sa prof
habituel et on a vraiment des kébé des
conseils de musicalité d'interprétation
on sent que ça va être plus joli à faire
du coup on prend confiance en soi et ce
sera mieux pendant que c'est ce que je
ressens une semaine de travail
récompensé par un concert le temps d'une
soirée la salle jacques brel sera pour
eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]